okay thank you for the invitation to
presented lab roots my name is adam
burak and i did the work that you're
about to see
uh with my hands in the lab of dr ingen
stromnis
at the university of minnesota
so our specific interest is
interrogating mechanisms of
tumor-specific t-cell exhaustion and
activity
in pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
so to begin with our research problem
that we're addressing with our model
system and then interrogating t cells
within that model system
is really a lack
for the field of an antigen-specific
t-cell model to study
why immunotherapy fails in pancreas
cancer
um
the reason underlying that lack of a
model is that there are vanishingly few
pancreas cancer-specific t-cell
responses that responses that have been
characterized in patients
so we really
don't understand how t cells fail to
attack pancreas cancer
so in the basic immunology field which
is where i
work mouse models
um there is an oval bumin ovalbumin
positive pancreas cancer cell line that
has been made
however these
tumor cells when they're injected into
mice are overtly rejected
or
they lose antigen over time so we really
can't study
in this model what immunologists would
call t cell exhaustion and how t cells
respond to treatments like immune
checkpoint blockade
sort of exemplified by pdl1 blockade
so a potential rate limiting factor for
t cell access to tumors even if they
were t
were tumor specific
is the uh so-called fibro-inflammatory
micro-environment
that characterizes pancreatic cancer
which may restrict blood flow and
because blood flow is restricted and
that's how t-cells would get into the
tumor beds that may
be why there are few t cells within
pancreas cancer
regardless of anagen specificity
so to begin to address these problems in
in the basic model in mice
we transduced several different
um
kpc mouse derived um cell lines which is
what these kpc one two three are
on the left um
with a construct
containing click beetle red luciferase
as well as gfp
so click beetle red facilitates
tumor imaging by luminescence over time
as the tumor grows
and when we made these cell lines when
we transduce these cell lines with this
construct gfp
or fitzy expression is how we sorted
our cells that were transduced
so the cell line that we used primarily
in this cell reports paper that was
published in 2019 is this kpc2
and then this a
line here um
the top red on that graph on the left
that cell line was well well transduced
with our construct so we could
orthotopically inject the cell line into
the pancreas of mice and visualize tumor
cells over time
and the the main point here
of showing the immunofluorescence
imaging on the right is in this
orthotopic model on the bottom
we see that there there is
a degree of fibril inflammation that
does develop over time over several
weeks following tumor cell injection
uh alpha smooth muscle actin is one of
the markers of um the fibroblasts
in these in these orthotopic tumors
we also have f480 positive macrophages
in red some cda t cells in yellow
and some neutrophils by lysix g staining
in purple in these tumors so a range of
immunostill threat
the tumors grow
through well
and we have a model system
one defining factor of pancreas cancer
clinically is that it resists immune
checkpoint blockade pd1 and pdl1 were
tried in initial studies
in 2012 and 2013
and patients resisted these therapies
however in our model system where the
tumor cells express this clickfuel gfp
construct tumor luminescence decreases
following these treatments shown on the
left we have very bright tumors at day
seven
and then following uh treatment which is
initiated at day seven and then it's
another treatment on day two at 10 and
day 12 after tumor cell injection these
tumors
have less luminescence following that
treatment whether we block
a pdl one
on the bottom middle
or pd1 on the bottom right luminescence
goes down over time and at three weeks
after tumor cell injection we have
significantly less tumor luminescence
consistent with a tumor-specific t-cell
response we would hope
so another um
observation that is consistent with a t
cell response against our model antigen
potentially or at least against our
tumor specifically
is the presence of cd8 t cells by
immunofluorescence staining in these
tumors
as noted by the yellow staining in these
images and arrows pointing to those
yellow cells
quantified on the right
um even without the pdl1 treatment
um
in the number of cd8 cells per field of
view graph on the middle right we have a
large number of cd8 cells per field of
view without pdl1 treatment and then in
the green we all we still have a large
number of cd8 cells per field of view
in addition below that on the bottom
right we have
a relatively high intensity for pdl1
staining in the tumors and untreated
mice just with the kpc 2a cell line
shown in red and that intensity of pdl1
staining is maintained
following pdl-1 blockade
so this would suggest that there's
probably a fair degree of interferon
gamma
expression in these tumors by cda t
cells which is promoting that pdl-1
expression by either tumor cells or
tumor-associated myeloid cells
and again that would be consistent with
a tumor-specific cd8 t-cell response
occurring
strikingly and the reason this paper was
well received
by reviewers was pdl one blockade
presumably to this model antigen
prolonged mouse survival as shown in the
survival curve on the bottom left of
this of this slide
we can also quantify tumor volume by
ultrasound imaging in addition to
luminescence which is the only method
that would quantify
tumor
size in the absence of this
luminescent molecule so in cell lines
that either don't express the construct
at all this parental kpc2 line and the
top middle or the gfp only control cell
line our tumor volumes did not decrease
following
uh pdl1 uh
treatment vl1 blockade whereas the click
beetle expressing line that those tumors
were smaller following pdl one blockade
um
the weights
tumor weights at day 22 were consistent
with this smaller volume and pdl one
treated mice that received our kpc
two-way cell line
sorry um
in contrast pdl1 blockade treatment as i
mentioned earlier did not did not
prolong mouse survival did not decrease
tumor volume or tumor weight
in the absence of this click fetal
molecule
so that would suggest that we have a
specific t cell response to some some
peptide derived from that quick needle
protein
so our next step was to figure out
using um algorithms to predict peptides
and then an empirical test of
the highest scoring peptides derived
from that protein
what our immunodominant
class 1 mhc class 1 restricted peptide
was that cda t cells were responding to
so these in the top left
the numbers on the bottom of this graph
are the initial amino acid of the
peptides that we tested so this peptide
beginning at amino acid 101 of the
protein was our our winner in this
competitive assay
in vivo we saw the most interview on
gamma production to that peptide so we
went ahead and made an mhc class 1
restricted h2dfb is the class 1
that we
were testing here
restricted tetramer reagent and could
detect specific cells in vaccinated mice
and also in tumor bearing mice
so following this discovery we had
a handle
to study tumor-specific cells and
pancreas cancer
so we did the first thing a lot of
immunologists think of is immune
responses sort of evolve and happen over
time so we did a time course we looked
at these tetramer binding cells in the
blood the spleen and the tumor on day 7
day 14 day 22
and in mice that were treated with pdl
one blockade day 43 after tumor cell
injection
and when we dated on our cd8 positive t
cells we found robust populations of
tetramer binding cells at all of these
time points and in all of these
locations
consistent with the premise that t cells
get into these tumors
just fine
the tumor itself does not restrict t
cell infiltration
and even in untreated mice with large
tumors at day 22 the control
there were between 30 and 40 percent of
the cda t cells found our tetramer so
there are
in this model plenty of tumor-specific t
cells in the tetramer and in the tumor
and the tumor continues to grow so that
would suggest that the cells in the
untreated mice get exhausted
or something similar where they cannot
kill the tumor
cells and with pl1 blockade that process
is perturbed somehow
so
one one possibility would be canonical
um t-cell exhaustion which
um
could be defined as co-expression of the
inhibitory markers pd-1 leg 3 tim 3 and
tidget on our tetramer binding cells and
these pie charts are probably the most
useful way to look at this we think
in the tumor
at in either untreated mice
the darker the darker these pie chart
areas
all four of these markers are expressed
slightly lighter three lighter yet two
just a little bit gray as one and then
the white is none of these markers
expressed and the entire pie chart
represents all of our tetramer binding t
cells
so in the tumor and untreated mice at
late time points we have about half of
our cells that bind the tetramer express
either either three or four of these
canonical exhaustion markers
whereas if you compare on the right pdl
one treated mice outlined with the red
outline of the circle the majority of
the tetramer binding cells at the same
time point are expressing either zero or
one of those canonical exhaustion
markers and in this case the one tended
to be pd-1
which is generally thought of as more
specific to t cell antigen encounter
rather than exhaustion per se
in our in our hands in this model um the
combination of pd1 with leg 3 expression
on the same t cell appears to correlate
better with an exhausted phenotype than
just pd1 itself
in addition
um in the anti-pdl one treated mice
the uh the uh peptide specific cells
retain the ability to produce interferon
gamma in an ex vivo restimulation
experiment
uh more effectively than in untreated
mice
um this is quantified on the right so
we're comparing untreated mice to pdl
one blockade treated mice this is at the
three weeks after tumor cell injection
time point and look look in particular
here at the cells isolated from these
tumors we have a higher proportion
of cda t cells able to produce
interferon gamma in response to click
beetle peptide restimulation in a cell
culture dish for four hours
so that would suggest that treatment
helps t cells either
either one retain function
or b
potentially a new wave of effector t
cells is stimulated from the spleens of
these mice
okay so
the next observation was i mentioned
earlier that our that leg 3 may be a
better
marker of t cell exhaustion than pd1
our best marker of t cell activation
turns out in this system is klrg1
expression
and it appears to be
more or less a binary choice for an
individual t cell to become either
a leg three positive exhausted cell or a
klr g1 positive effector cell
following treatment
and at about at about the time
that i was going to start
um combining therapies a paper came out
in a different model of cancer it was a
melanoma paper
where they combined pd-1 blockade with
pdl-1 blockade with a hypothesis that
pd-1 blockade would activate t-cells and
pdl-1 blockade would activate the
macrophages
and in that paper
they saw a benefit of this dual therapy
and i
thought that would be cool to try in
this system so we did and i was agnostic
on whether
pdl one blockade was activating
macrophages or not but we gave the dual
therapy a shot
and in the green line here you can see
that we cured half of those mice that
was really
satisfying
we did a lot of treatments here we
treated these mice with both pd-1 and
pdl-1 blockade from day 7 to day 28
after tumor injection
so that was a lot of antibody and a lot
of treatments but we did cure half the
mice and we
promoted these the klrg1 expression
over leg three expression uh quantified
in this bottom row of plots
so that was really satisfying to cure
mice of a model antigen expressing
pancreas cancer model
so one question we could ask having
developed this model where we can cure
pancreas cancer is
is starting in therapy at day seven
after tumor cell injection required or
could we delay therapy because as the
audience is probably aware pancreas
cancer is generally diagnosed pretty
late in the process stage three four
so in this model it turns out that
delaying therapy is a big problem
on the right if we delay our dual
therapy which can cure half the mice
if we delay the start of that by one
week and do that first treatment on day
14 instead of day 7
it looks much more like the survival
curve of our single therapy started
earlier and if we delay the single
therapy start date by a week
it is essentially no benefit to the mice
so timing matters
so to summarize this first part our
model antigen represents a very high
affinity uh peptide interaction with mhc
which primes a really strong t cell
response so some further questions that
we can ask is
what what specifically is driving
intra-tumor t-cell exhaustion what
prototype protein expression identifies
this state on the t-cells and can we
improve
with this knowledge can we improve our
success rate of our therapy
so this moves into another publication
that just came out recently in the
journal of immunology where we
interrogate these questions
and we did
not surprisingly for immunologists
another time course so in this case
we're looking at expression of different
proteins on our tetramer binding t cells
in the spleen and the tumor over time
so on the on the left is a as a visual
summary of this uh spleen cells that
find tetramer are blue two are in red
and we're looking at tox expression
which signifies
antigen experience or perhaps ongoing
antigen experience
and granzyme b which is one of your key
contact mediated
factors that t cells express that cause
target cell death
so at day seven we have a lot of both of
these in the tumor
at day 14 we've maintained tox but are
losing grant sign b and in day 21 we
have maintained tox but we have lost
grand sign b
so that's that's essentially the story
our t cells in the tumor continue to
express anagen indicated by tox but they
lose grand b expression so they can no
longer kill tumor cells
in addition
on the right on the bottom
graph
in the tumor
the proportion of tetramer binding cells
that are able to express interferon
gamma also goes down energy on gamma is
another critical
cytolytic molecule that cda t cells
express
so two different ways to kill tumors and
our t cells lose both of them over time
so in addition to tox maintenance and
grand zombie loss and interferon gamma
loss over time another component of t
cell exhaustion in the tumors in our
model system is
t cells acquire gfp expression or not
gfp expression il-10 expression so our
cancer binding cells begin to express
il-10 over time
as shown on the right
using il-10 reporter mice so it's a gfp
reporter mouse um the cells that are gfp
positive those in the tumor
tend to express pd1 leg 3 digit tim 3
our canonical exhaustion
signature from the first paper
so as these cells become exhausted they
are
maintaining tox losing granzyme losing
interference gamma gaining il-10 so
what's driving this
the first thing we tried was to block
all these co-inhibitory markers in
combination with pl1 blockade or
individually and clearly from the
survival curve that did not help so
messing with the phenotype at the end
when they express all of these
exhaustion markers is not effective so
we need to move upstream in the process
and
uh one way that we could go about trying
to interrogate what that was that was
driving all of these exhaustion markers
is to look in some of the clinical
databases
for
either cytokines or chemokines or growth
factors
that either the tumor cells themselves
express or the myeloid cells in the
tumors expressed that correlate with
impaired patient survival so we're
trying to find something that's
clinically relevant here
and it's really hard to make pancreas
cancer survival worse i spent a lot of
time in the database trying to find
something
il-27 is one of those things so high
expression of il-27 p28 within pancreas
cancer
actually makes pancreas cancer survival
worse
so lucky for us there's a reporter mouse
for il-27
cells that are expressing il-27 gene
those cells also express gfp
and as a proportion of cd45 positive
immune cells the proportion making il-27
goes up over time in the tumors
suggesting that our mouse model may be
reflecting what's happening in the human
disease where il-27 is not
useful
and this is weird and interesting
because il-27 is critical for t-cell
priming
and is actually really important in the
response elicited by type 1 dendritic
cells after vaccination
which is a topic for another time
but is why i was aware of this field
il-27 is really important for t-cell
priming and memory formation but too
much may be a bad thing
we did another time course and we
characterized which
myeloid cells in this case or non t
cells that are in the tumor are
expressing il 27 at either day 7 14 or
21 after tumor cell injection and at day
7 it was clearly granulocytes or
neutrophils that are
the main source of il27
at day 14 it was a mix of type 2
dendritic cells which in this case in
our gaining scheme are serb alpha
positive
along with macrophages tumor-associated
myelin macrophages
and some other cells including type 1
dendritic cells at day 14
and then several cell types of day 21 so
essentially our t cells that go into our
tumors
primed and ready to go from the spleen
encounter
just an ocean of il-27 and probably a
bunch of other suppresses cytokines and
that may be part
of
t cell exhaustion developing over time
cd40 agonist is in the clinic in
clinical trials to treat pancreas cancer
and some other malignancies so we
thought it was rational to try one
treatment with cd40 agonist at day seven
after tumor cell injection and see what
that did
to il-27 expression by various immune
cell types
long story short we saw a big decrease
in il-27 signal with cd40 agonist single
therapy but not with our pdl-1 single
therapy which we already knew
prolonged survival and had effects on t
cells so it appears here from these data
that c40 agonist is affecting the
myeloid cells
qualitatively
in addition
il-10 expression
um is downstream of il-27 receptor
signaling
so it was rational
in our minds at least to think that
il-27 exposure
of t-cells could have been driving that
il-10 expression that we saw earlier
with the reporter mouse
and it turned out that cd40 agonist
treatment on the left decreased the
proportion of cd8 t cells that were il10
positive in the il-10 reporter mouse
whereas pdl1 blockade did not
in addition cd40 agonist on the right
shown on the right um promoted grands iv
expression
by our uh tetramer binding t cells which
again pdl1 blockade did not
so two different therapies
both effective to a degree doing very
different things
so we did the
immunologist thing and we put them
together
very simple treatment schematic here
are three treatments of pdl one blockade
at day seven ten and twelve one
treatment of cd40 agonist
and we cured 10 out of 16 mice with the
dual therapy group which is really
really satisfying
um in ibis imaging shown on the right
we essentially don't see these tumors
luminescent at all
after we initiate therapy with this dual
therapy it's
it's gone until it comes back much later
in the mice where it does come back and
in many of the mice it does not
through some phenotypic analysis it
appears that cd40 agonist promotes uh
what we're calling in this in this
publication a short-lived effector
t-cell phenotype
so in the blue
and the blue dots for cd48 in a single
therapy at day 14 we're seeing a lot of
those klrg1 positive cells
we're seeing
we're seeing a decrease in tox
expression we're seeing a decrease in
pd1 expression and we're seeing a
decrease in leg 3 expression on our
tetramer binding cells so again remember
the combination of pd1 and leg 3 is our
exhaustion phenotype
and we're seeing essentially fewer of
those and more of these klrg1 positive
cells
earlier
consistent with a really strong response
really quick and you just get rid of the
tumor
at later time points
like three months after tumor cell
injection when the mice have had no
luminescence for two months or so
we see
tetramer binding cells not only in the
pancreas and the spleen which you would
expect but also in sites of potential
tumor metastasis the liver in the lung
shown on the left we had over ten
percent of the cd8 t cells
by flow cytometry in those locations um
found the tetramer
but interestingly
um in the pancreas is where our tetramer
binding cells express the residency
markers cd49a and cd103
in addition if we re-challenge these
mice that have cured a previous tumor
with a second tumor in the pancreas
a hundred days after the first tumor um
the tetramer binding cells expanded
10-fold to 100-fold in the blood the
spleen in the pancreas consistent with
really robust t-cell memory responses
uh two two straightforward things that
uh classically trained immunologists
would ask in this setting are is what
what are
what effector molecules is this response
dependent on and the first two
that came to mind for us were interferon
gamma and tnf alpha because those are
the those are the cytokines that we look
for in our peptide restimulation
experiments
and for example transplant rejection
requires essentially both of these
interferon gamma in the blue
the blue dotted lines are untreated mice
the blue solid line is our dual treated
mice
um you'll see the blue solid line goes
straight down at day 40 which means that
our dual therapy had very little benefit
in mice that did not have interferon
gamma receptor signaling suggesting that
this is an absolute requirement for our
effector t-cell response
as probably expected
in sharp contrast the
green solid line is tnf receptor one
knockout mice
and in those mice
we actually had four out of four mice
cured and remained cured
with our dual therapy
so this would suggest that somehow
tnf receptor one signaling may be
impairing
either the effector response or the
memory response to these tumors
so the last experiment that i'll present
oops the last experiment that i'll
present this sequence is looking at the
memory t cells and either our
our regular b6 mice on the top two
panels
or tnf receptor one knockout mice on the
bottom two panels and what we see
immediately are a higher proportion of
cd62 ligand cd44 double positive
so-called central memory cells
in the knockout mice on the bottom left
and coexpression on the right
of cxcr3 and klrt1 on some of those
cells
in the receptor knockout mice so this is
something we're pursuing now and it
really suggests that there may be
qualitative differences in
memory t cell generation when you don't
have tnf receptor signaling
um that's that's one of the main thrusts
of an r1 that we just started so that'll
be really exciting to interrogate
moving forward
so to summarize quick uh we show in this
second paper that tumor-specific t-cells
lose grand b and interferon gamma
within the tumor specifically while they
maintain tox expression
suggesting that they're continuing to
see antigen and they gain il-10
we found that cd40 agonist ablates
chronic myeloid cell il-27 expression
along with t-cell il-10 expression and
promotes t-cell grant sign b and
k-l-r-g-1 expression consistent with a
short-lived effector phenotype
and given these
really broad differences in the effects
of cd40 agonist and pdl1 blockade
it is not surprising that these two
therapies synergize
and further benefit in the absence of
tdf receptor signaling which is really
intriguing and again a main
a main direction for us moving forward
a couple quick acknowledgments firstly
and most importantly incan
inconstrumness for the opportunity to do
the work in her lab
and everybody in the lab too many to
thank
and our our new r01 on this project
thank you again for the opportunity
um i'll be happy to answer any questions